[Music] What on earth is
that determination inside of you?
Are you determined? Do you look like that sometimes? It's
like the eyes of someone standing on the battlefield.
If you can stick to this belief, you don't care if you die here. That's how determined you are.  I have the
eyes of something,
but I haven't given up on sex, and
I'm trying to resist until the very last moment.The moment I have to kill that thing is the
most
terrifying thing, and the thing that scares me the most is the fact that
I'm the one being killed.  I sometimes
have dreams where I wake up from a dream and am here,
living properly, but sometimes I get very scared.The
truth is that I have already died, and the
world I am living in now is the
long dream that I am seeing after I die.  I had this feeling inside of me, thinking, ``It's because I'm
scared,''
but I've decided that no matter
what the outcome of this life is, I don't want to run away.
Just be prepared to live as your wife.
[Music] That's a
big deal. You do
n't have to be prepared to be my wife.
[Music]